queueing to get into a charity rap
concert in istanbul's category district
hundreds of russians here united in
showing their opposition to their
country's war in ukraine and support for
the ukrainian fight to stop the invasion
most of them are young and well-educated
russians
if you write
more in your
instagram or
facebook
you can go to the hotel yeah
others say they were arrested for
joining anti-war protests in cities back
home
not long time before i
got arrested because i took part in some
morales and
i got fired
also in istanbul is alisa zaiseva the
russian activist left moscow two weeks
ago to cram her life into the small room
in hostel she has a russian passport but
half of her family is ukrainian like
many of her peers she was born after
russian president vladimir putin was
elected we never chose him we literally
had
votes rights just a couple years ago we
never voted for this
government people feel guilty
young generation that they
trying to do something but it's
impossible and it's dangerous
but living in turkey means many
challenges lie ahead the russian
anti-war newcomers need a life to settle
housing money
due to the crippling international
sanctions their credit cards don't work
most have no plan
it's pretty nice and clean and it's good
enough
eva rappaport is an anthropology
researcher who left russia nine years
ago she has been in istanbul for nearly
two years and stayed out of politics but
now she helps other russians who fled to
get a roof over their heads
i cannot go on and
do my regular daily routines when
something like so unjust and like so
uncalled for is
happening
others in self-exile fear for the future
and putin's potential revenge
when he turns back from the war he will
turn his eyes to the people that did not
support his actions
and that will be war inside
as well as russians some ukrainians also
ended up in istanbul uric is married to
a russian in kazan but felt he wasn't
safe there or in his hometown kiev
either
it's really sad that
russian people
they worry about their economy when
our people die turkey is one of the
easier destinations to escape to for
russians who are against war but even if
fighting in ukraine ends soon russians
may face 15-year prison sentence if they
return home because of their social
media pause and their opposition to the
invasion
senator solo al jazeera istanbul